a statistician for a basketball team
tracked the number of points that each
of the 12 players on the team had in one
game and then made a stem
and the leaf plot to show the data and
sometimes it's called a stem plot how
many points did the team score and when
you first look at this plot right over
here it seems a little hard to
understand under stem you have zero one
two under leaf you have all of these
digits here how does this relate to the
number of points each student or each
player actually scored and the way to
interpret a stem and leaf plot is the
leaves contain at least the way that
this statistician used it the leaf
contains the the smallest digit or the
ones digit in the number of points that
each player scored and the stem contains
the tens digits and usually the leaf
will contain the the right most digit or
the ones digits and then the stem will
contain all of the other digits and
what's useful about this is it gives
kind of a distribution of where the
players were you see that most of the
players scored points that started with
a zero then a few more scored points
that started with a one and then only
one score scored points that started
with a two and it was actually 20 points
so let me actually write down all of
this data in a way that maybe you're a
little bit more used to understanding it
so i'm going to write the zeros in
purple so there's let's see one two
three four five six seven players had
zero as the first digit so one two
three
four
five
six
seven i wrote seven zeros
and then this player also had a zero in
his ones digit
this player i'm gonna try to do all the
colors this player also had a zero in
his ones digit
this player right here had a two in his
ones a digit so he scored a total of two
points
this player let me do orange this player
had four for his ones digit this player
had seven for his ones digit
then this player had seven for his ones
digit and then
let me see i'm almost using all the
colors this player had nine for his ones
digit so the way to read this is you had
one player with zero points zero two
four seven nine and nine but you can see
i'm just kind of silly saying the zero
was a tens digit you could have even put
a blank there but the zero lets us know
that they didn't score they didn't score
anything in the tens place but these are
the actual scores for those seven
players now let's go to the next row in
the stem and leaf plot so over here all
of the digits start with or all of the
point to start with one for each of the
players and there's four of them so one
one
and one
and then we have this player over here
it's one his ones digit or her one's
digit is a one
so this player this represents 11
one in the tens place one in the ones
place
this player over here also got eleven
one in the tens place one in the ones
place
this player let me do orange this player
has three in the ones place so he or she
scored 13 points one in the tens place
one three in the ones place 13 points
and then i will do this in purple this
player has eight in their ones place
so he or she scored 18 points one in the
tens place eight in the ones place 18
points and then finally you have this
player that has two
the the tens digit is a 2
and then the ones digit is a 0
is a 0. i'll circle that in yellow it is
a 0. so he or she scored 20 points so
using the using looking at the stem and
leaf plot we were able to extract out
all of the number of points that all of
the players scored and once again what
was useful about this is you see how
many players scored between zero and
nine points including nine points homie
scored between 10 and 19 points and then
how many scored 20 points or over and
you see the distribution right over here
but let's actually answer the question
that they're asking us to answer
how many points did the team score so
here we just have to add up all of these
numbers right over here so we're going
to add up i'll start with the largest so
plus 18
plus 13
plus 11
plus 11 13 11 11 plus 9
plus 7
plus seven again
plus four
plus two did i do that right we have two
elevens then a nine then two sevens then
a four then a two and then these two
characters didn't score anything so
let's add up all of these together
let's add them all up
so
0 plus 8 is 8 plus 3 is 11 plus 1 is 12
plus 1 is 13 plus 9 is 22 plus 7 is 27
or 40.
so that gets us to 40. let me do that
one more time 8 11
11 12
13 22 29
and then
29 36 40 and 42.
looks like i actually might have missed
let me do it one more time this is the
hardest part adding these up so let me
try that one last time i'm just going to
state where my sum is so 0 8 at 3 11
13 22 29 36
40 42 so it's good thing that i double
checked that i had made a mistake the
first time
4 plus 2 is 6 7 8 9 10
so we get to 102 points the team in
total scored 102
points